ja nicht nur politische aspekte dieser
reise die werden heute diskutiert auch
im internet ist eine diskussion
entstanden und zwar eine modische
diskussion ja das klingt jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen komisch aber dass politiker
ihr aussehen ihre kleidung sehr bewusst
für die image pflege einsetzen ist gang
und gäbe und es lohnt sich also durchaus
einen näheren blick auf des kanzlers
kleider
olaf scholz auf wichtige außenpolitische
mission in kiel zusammen mit italiens
ministerpräsident reggae und frankreichs
präsident prof alle drei im klassischen
politiker look anders bei der anreise
draghi macht klassischen italienischen
herren freizeitlook eine bella figura
eine gute figur marco als gastgeber im
eigenen waggon wirkt auch präsidial
nation im weißen hemd und olaf scholz im
schwarzen kurz am polo souveränen look
oder unangemessen für ein deutsches
staatsoberhaupt im netz unter anderem
bei twitter sorgt hashtag kurzarmhemd
für diskussionen
kurzarmhemd ist nun wirklich nicht das
problem wohl eher dass es anmutet als ob
scholz sich auf klassenfahrt befindet
ausgelassen und voller vorfreude ab ins
kriegsgebiet geht es noch
so glücklich kann nur schauen wer ein
kurzarmhemd regt
internationaler kongress der
schrebergärten förderation in kiew fakt
ist diese fotos gehen um die welt auch
bei der anreise im hotel radio marca im
seriösen politiker look und unser
bundeskanzler immer noch mit seinem
kurzarmhemd und salopp an chips im netz
und bei social media gibt es auch
verständnis für den scholz lockt wenn
ich elf stunden mit dem zug in ein
kriegsgebiet fahre ziehe ich immer einen
zweireiher und zählen wie konnte er uns
nur so bloßstellen deutschland eine
nation von modeberater
ihr fordert wochenlang dass olaf in die
ukraine fährt und jetzt diskutiert er
über seinen coach
jetzt fährt er schon nach kiew nimmt
sogar den zug sichert der ukraine volle
solidarität zu und hat quasi waffen im
gepäck und ihr meckert ernsthaft über
seinen kurzarmhemd leute leute
kurzarmhemd und schied nicht das erste
mal dass ein olaf scholz outfit für
gesprächsstoff sorgt wir erinnern uns an
den scholz schlumpf super bequem einige
nummern zu groß zurück in die ukraine
nach der anreise hat sich olaf scholz
umgezogen und dann alle termine im
seriösen politiker look absolviert diese
lenski dagegen im gewohnten militär t
shirt auch das ein statement mode ist
dem manchmal politik
unser fashion experte entschuldigung
erst natürlich parlaments chef aber
unserer redaktion aber er kann natürlich
auch dazu was sagen ralf schuler das ist
ein bisschen
unangemessen
so ein freizeit look auf so einer
wichtigen reise es ist etwas
unangemessen also jeder weiß der in
diesem amt ist dass jede nuance tor
zählt und natürlich weiß auch sie lenski
dass der kampfanzug dass das grüne t
shirt eine bedeutung hat er ist
permanent im kriegs modus und natürlich
auch jemand der dort hinfährt um einen
der größten konflikte der jetztzeit
irgendwie zu beenden zu bearbeiten zu
besprechen dann wird zu sagen im
feierabend look dort anreist und das
eigentliche outfit nur als kostüm dann
zieht das ist schon etwas unangemessen
es ist vor allen dingen deshalb blöd
weil es den fokus von dem eigentlichen
wirklich schweren politischen
hintergrund ablenkt und da hätte es ein
einfaches lockeres weißes hemd auch
getan makro macht das vor auch der
pullover von von draghi es ist locker es
ist entspannt und trotzdem nicht
protokollarisch lässig sowie scholz ich
weiß nicht ob er da beraten wird was ob
er das selbst auswählt hier geht es
sozusagen jemand fährt ins wochenende
und offensichtlich zieht dass ich dann
um und macht seinen job das finde ich
schwierig aber es sind natürlich lassen
wo dann
die die bundesregierung sagen wird ja
gott ihr guckt wieder auf die
nebensachen wichtig ist was rauskommt es
erstaunt allerdings schon ein wenig weil
du sagst es ja ist ja nun kein
politischer anfänger er ist schon sehr
lange dabei müsste doch selber
eigentlich wissen dass eben auch
äußerlichkeiten das outfit in der
politik eben auch eine menge zu bedeuten
haben dass das immer interpretiert wird
wir erinnern uns zum beispiel an den
griechischen finanzminister fakt ist er
hatte damals lederklamotten plötzlich an
kam auf seiner harley daher und hat dann
plötzlich auch ein ganz neues wähler
volk hinter sich versammelt glaubens
waren 100 aber ich bin nicht bin ich
sicher und ich bin kein motorrad experte
absolut er hat das eben auch kultivierte
sozusagen der der rocker der modernen
zeit bei olaf scholz passt es aus meiner
sicht nicht mal zum typ denn für seine
lässigkeit ist ja nun wirklich nicht
bekannt ganz großer inszenierung ist
halt wladimir putin bei der jagd freier
oberkörper reitend usw das eine ganz
klare dominanz gesten das ist hier nun
eine eine kleinigkeit aber man weiß
einfach dass all das eine rolle spielt
und niemand wird in dieser position
fotografiert ohne dass das will
man fragt sich welche zeichen er da
wirklich setzen möchte ein anderes
zeichen was ja auch gesetzt wurde war
waren die bilder aus den daten die
staats und regierungschefs keine
schusssicheren westen an sie waren da
aber trotzdem natürlich im feinsten
zwirn wie hast du das gesehen ja das
sollte ganz offensichtlich zeigen dass
man sich nicht ins bockshorn jagen lässt
dass man sich nicht verunsichern lässt
und eigentlich die politik über dem
kriegsgeschehen steht anders als bei der
außenministerin beispielsweise die ja
mit schusssicherer weste und helm darum
lief hat zeigt man hier wir sind
diejenigen die politisch die
geostrategischen fäden ziehen das war
auch eine bewusste geste es hätte
allerdings in dem outfit auch sehr
seltsam ausgesehen so eine weste darüber
zu ziehen das ist wohl richtig
dankeschön ralf schuler für deine
einschätzung zu diesen klamotten geld